uh so we are going to see some rain in
southern nevada today i think that is
pretty much for sure but we're not
guaranteeing rain in every neighborhood
we're also not talking about major
accumulation there may be what we call
periods of brief heavy downpour in some
neighborhoods great view from this
camera on the molaskey family company's
bank of america buildings rainbow on the
95 looking out to the south end to the
east and there's definitely rain that is
building up we'll get to the future cast
here in a second 106 out at reed
international same temp out at the air
force base 105 along the strip
close to triple digits now this cloud
cover is probably going to cap off the
afternoon temperatures but still
obviously pretty warm and you talk about
warm 115 right now for death valley over
the hump and from you're probably going
to see some scattered showers later this
afternoon most of it's going to be
concentrated here in the las vegas
valley as well as northwestern arizona
and on up into lincoln county and
southwestern utah we may make it up to
108 that will be a few degrees above
normal low this morning 10 degrees above
normal so let's get right into this
future cast this is a projection of
where clouds and rain may be
by one o'clock it looks like the
henderson neighborhoods as well as up
towards indian springs at two o'clock we
start to see a little break except for
southern highlands and seven hills then
between three four and five it's going
to stay to the south of us but by the
time we get to seven o'clock there's a
really good chance of some more stuff
developing before rolling right out of
here now here's the actual radar the
storms are approaching from northwestern
arizona moving to the north and to the
west ted florenda will certainly keep
you posted throughout the rest of the
day some scattered storms collapsing
south of dallas so it's going to stay
hot that's for sure the storm clouds
linger tomorrow we think it will start
to dry out into the weekend and
temperatures holding around 108 keep it
right here for all your weather updates
heather all right nate we know you're
watching the sky thank you still